I'm here at the Navy's indoor ocean at
carderock this is the biggest wave pool
in the world and they can make all kinds
of different waves so they can test
scale ships and make them better before
they actually go out on the open ocean
I came in and I'd seen some pictures but
I just walked in here and it's just it's
insane because they say indoor ocean but
like it's exactly what it is the water
even looks ocean colored it doesn't look
like a swimming pool this looks like an
ocean it looks like a test facility it
is huge it is 360 feet long in this
Dimension 240 feet long in that
Dimension it's 20 feet deep just about
the size of a football field out there
the Dome above us was the largest
freestanding dome for a while largest
freestanding dome in the world yep what
in this pool they can make waves of all
shapes and sizes using huge paddles that
line two walls of the pool we have 216
individual wave makers we can make ways
from negative 45 degrees up to 135
degrees which is kind of coming right
back at it
we are now behind the big paddles that
make the waves
these 216 paddles are programmed to move
in incredibly well choreographed ways so
that they can produce reproducible
perfect size perfect frequency waves
that go across the entire pool you can
see these air Bellows that are what's
making the angular motion that vertical
piece is the force transducer the other
Force transducers right up on the top
there are lots of wave pools in the
world but what makes this one different
is control you can create waves of a
specific amplitude and frequency and do
so repeatedly should we try a one Hertz
yeah do me a favor and dial up one hurts
hey go ahead and send it from zero
please
and so this is the largest wave we can
make at one Hertz that's based on the
motion and power requirement for the
Waymaker
there's something a bit like surreal
about watching this because
it almost looks like an ocean except you
never see waves this regular out there
correct
one of the fundamental characteristics
of a wave is its wavelength the distance
from one Crest to the next the first
thing most people learn about waves is
they transmit energy rather than
material from one place to another in
this case as the wave travels to the
right the water molecules themselves
basically Move Along circular paths and
the deeper the water the smaller this
motion all motion stops at a depth equal
to half the wavelength this is known as
the wave base
but even in an ideal water wave the
molecules do drift a bit in the
direction of wave motion and this is
because the molecules travel faster the
higher up they are so they move farther
at the top of their Loop then they move
backwards at the bottom creating a
spiral path
this place is perfect for observing
properties of different waves I asked
Miguel to show me some waves with
different frequencies but the same
amplitude so what I'll have them do now
is I'll have them stop this wave and
this changed the frequency
because we're at 0.6 we'll go to 0.5 so
it'll be a two second wave
here I'm split screening waves with
frequencies of 0.67 0.5 and 0.33 Hertz
all with the same amplitude
so two things to notice even though they
all have the same amplitude the ones
with higher frequency look like they
have a greater amplitude because the
slope of the waves is steeper and second
the frequency of a wave affects its
speed high frequency waves travel slower
than low frequency waves in fact as long
as the water is deeper than the wave
base wave speed is inversely
proportional to its frequency
they have a really cool demo that takes
advantage of the different speeds of
different frequency waves you can see it
starting here they send out high
frequency waves first followed by lower
and lower frequency waves and because
the high frequency waves travel slower
the lower frequency waves gradually
catch up
wow
and they've timed it so that all the
waves meet up at exactly the same time
and place in the pool this causes the
wave to break
the ocean Engineers can do this again
and again
in exactly the same way thanks to their
precise control over the waves
this demo also nicely illustrates the
principle of superposition that when
waves meet they add together the height
of the water is equal to the sum of the
heights of the individual waves meeting
at that point
you can see how much bigger the
amplitude is those individual waves
weren't that big but when you add them
all together you can make this big
breaking wave
they can also take advantage of the
superposition principle to create
standing waves so what's coming up next
are two regular waves coming at each
other
what we call the quilt wave so we're
going to have a wave coming this way and
a wave going this way and it's going to
create standing waves so there's two
regular waves coming out and if you look
at the waves it looks like a big quilt
pattern out there
at some places in the pool the waves
always cancel out to zero amplitude and
at other places the waves add up for
maximum amplitude
they can even send waves from all
directions so they form circular wave
fronts and then all the wave energy is
channeled into one spot they call the
bullseye foreign
so now we're going to run the bullseye
way which is essentially the same thing
but instead of having a line of waves
we're having it all coalesce at one
individual point
so you can start seeing the waves are
coming from the long bank here and you
can see they're making a spherical wave
and then you have another spherical wave
coming from the short Bank
and this is breaking due to the
coalescing waves and the wave height
being more than one seventh of the
wavelength
we tried throwing some toys into the
wave to see what would happen to them
would they get pushed into the breaking
wave
even though there's not much net
movement of the water the ducky drifts
with the waves and pretty quickly is
pushed into the bullseye
to the danger zone right now
starting to funnel them right into that
breaking wave enough
oh
it swamped it that's amazing that was
right where we wanted it
now the real purpose of this facility is
not to play with toys or make perfect
unnatural waves it is to replicate on a
small scale the types of waves Navy
ships will encounter in the oceans of
the world
research Engineers Place ships modeled
after billion-dollar vessels in the
water to see how different designs
actually behave in real world conditions
right now this is coming from 45 degrees
it's going to be about a five inch
significant wave height which if we were
to scale it up for this model would be
20 foot waves when we're doing a free
running model like this we usually run
like a race track like a big circle or a
figure eight track so we know the
headings that we're running in so that
we can correlate that to you know the
full-scale vessel
for the model to provide an accurate
representation of the real world a lot
of things must be taken into account
is the water fresh water okay not salty
nope fresh water so when you're in salty
water you're going to have a lot more
buoyancy so when we're balancing our
models we have to make sure that they
take into account that buoyancy
difference so when we go full scale you
know you're the same conditions
for fluid mechanics I always expect that
you have to keep the Reynolds number the
same as in the real world phenomena but
actually to get the right wave Dynamics
you have to use a different scaling
which is based on the fruit number
so the fruit number is a measure of the
ratio of inertial to gravitational
forces it's equal to the flow velocity
divided by the square root of the
acceleration due to gravity times the
characteristic length like the length of
the ship in this case the model ship's
Hull is 46 times smaller than the real
thing which means to get accurate data
it should be traveling at one over the
square root of 46 times its real world
speed and to make the footage from the
model look the same as that from the
full-size ship you have to slow it down
by a factor of the square root of 46 so
roughly 6.8 times slower
I'm amazed at just how well these shots
match but of course that's the idea
scale the model and the waves so the
physics are identical to a real ship out
on the open ocean
naturally I asked if I could go swimming
in the pool but they said very kindly no
way the closest I could get would be on
a little dinghy is there a boat
with a catch
it's pretty smooth uh smooth sailing out
here right now yep no waves while we're
out here
so I'm assuming no one's ever been out
here in waves nope that's one of the
no-nos they don't want us to do like I
guess it's a risk thing so
this place seems like uh I don't know
like a massive playground it kind of is
for uh Engineers like us where it's we
kind of Dork out on the science and what
we're doing here it's it's a huge volume
like I I guess I never understood how
deep 20 feet was until they emptied it
to put in the new wave makers it's a
large volume just taken up by this water
um yeah so as we come by these are our
sensors right here we have a big array
here these are ultrasonic sensors and
that's how we measure wave height and
period and direction in Basin so we want
to make measure that to make sure that
what we test in is what we think we have
in this pool they can create all sorts
of different wave conditions you might
encounter in different parts of the
world
most ocean waves are created by wind and
the strongest winds occur in and around
storms
five factors affect the size and shape
of waves created these are the wind
speed the wind duration the distance
over which the wind is acting which is
known as the fetch the width of the
Fetch and the depth of the water
as waves travel out from a storm the
higher frequency waves dissipate their
energy more quickly so the waves that
travel a long way are the fast-moving
low frequency waves which are called
swell
when those waves end up becoming like
hundreds of miles away like if you have
it in the Pacific eventually you'll get
long periods to well from them so you're
no longer near the the storm but it
created enough energy to make long waves
and that's where you get your open ocean
swell tell me if this is a good analogy
I feel like with sound
a lot of the high frequencies will die
off quickly away from a source but the
low frequencies will travel much further
correct so is it the same thing with the
waves it's like like you're walking away
from a concert you can still hear like
the bass that's why you can't see any of
the high analogy yep what's the deal
with rogue waves
people like to think it's a rogue wave
where it just came out of nowhere and
this came up no it's usually multiple
waves that are meeting up and creating
an amplitude that's much larger than
what the self-standing wave would be so
when it meets it's going to break
because you have this large wave
creating this huge amplitude that it
just can't hold it and it breaks
on a calm day when you see waves
crashing at the beach around 10 seconds
apart that is swell but because of its
long wavelength swell isn't really a
concern for ships out in the open ocean
you know if you're on a long period as
well your ship's probably just going to
heave a little bit you're more worried
about the Steep waves and the windy
waves that are really moving you around
wind waves are formed in three steps
first as Wind Blows across the surface
of perfectly still water the turbulent
motion of the air creates regions of
slightly higher and slightly lower
pressure and this makes tiny ripples
with wavelengths of around a centimeter
but now the wind can act on these
ripples creating larger pressure
differences between the front and the
top of the wave Crest pulling them up
into bigger waves and the interaction of
the wind with these waves then creates
even larger pressure differences and
even larger waves
the waves are mostly uniform at this
point but as they interact with each
other they create a range of different
wavelength waves and as the wind keeps
blowing these waves begin breaking
transferring their kinetic energy into
swirling Eddies that dissipate their
energy as heat once the energy
dissipation matches the energy input
from the wind the waves have reached
their maximum size and this is known as
a fully developed sea
so this is going to be an irregular wave
this is irregular irregular wave so the
what you saw earlier with the regular
waves where one frequency one amplitude
this is what we call a Spectra or
multiple frequencies and multiple
amplitudes you can see that there's like
higher frequency with the waves that
kind of go travel slower than the low
frequency waves those low frequency
waves will travel fast and overcome them
and that's what's making them look peaky
or kind of dulling it out
what surprised me is that the different
oceans of the world have different
mixtures of wave frequencies or
different Spectra depending on their
geography and the types of storms that
occur there for example the North Sea
and other small bodies of water have a
peakier spectrum and this is due to the
limited fetch of storms that occur there
in the Mid-Atlantic a broader Spectrum
best describes the developing or
decaying open ocean waves that you'd
find there and in the North Atlantic the
steady wind across an open ocean
produces the broadest spectrum of wind
waves so when testing engineers first
have to figure out where the ship will
be deployed and which Spectra best match
these locations before creating them in
the pool
for most people I think an ocean is an
ocean but you're saying that there's
sort of like different conditions
depending on where you are they'll
Destroyer when I was in command we did
an operation off the coast of South
Korea in the spring very
rough sea keeping conditions but then
like when you're crossing the Pacific a
lot of that is a lot calmer so again you
know from there to the coast of South
Korea to the Arabian Gulf all those very
different conditions were there any
conditions that were particularly rough
for you so my bed was actually in the
middle of a room
and the seeds were so bad and this is
either south or east China Sea the Seas
were so bad that one night I woke up in
the middle of the night and my whole
mattress with me on it was sliding off
of my bed frame
and that's a pretty significantly sized
mattress so you can imagine the season
we were in that night
much bigger than this would terrify me I
know it probably looks benign but
I get much bigger than this I think that
model will take a lot of water
why do you care about how much water
goes on the deck
so on the back of this DDT is a
helicopter landing pad they don't want
any water on the deck when a helicopter
is about to land that's a big problem
you know that's one of the tests that we
do here is we'll put cameras to look at
the deck and understand how much water
wash is on
since I knew they wouldn't want to risk
their fancy model in rough conditions we
brought along a little remote controlled
boat to test
yeah I wouldn't be happy on that boat
a lot of people would be getting seasick
wow
oh no is it gone it's gone no it's right
there okay boom it's upside down
it was totally gone I was like in the
air and then it went under
now not all the models tested here can
be remote controlled so on the carriage
is what we're gonna do captive model
test where you could tether put Power
and instrumentation onto a model that
can't hold it itself so usually the
model will go in this Moon Bay right
here
the models are hooked up here and then
the whole Lab speeds over the waves
Towing the model underneath
people have been making ships for
thousands of years is there actually any
Innovation today most definitely so
sometimes you know people say that's the
way we've always done it and then when
you look into it there's some validity
to some hair brain ideas and when we
test them that's why you know you cut
your costs of doing a model test versus
building the full thing and saying oh
that didn't work every ship that's in
the Navy's fleet has gone through here
has gone through either our purview or
has been tested with perfectly with us
but all of the Navy owned ships have
been tested in this facility and there
is a ship out there with a tumble Home
Design where if you look at this ship
behind you it flares out so this flare
is usually what helps protect you from
when you start rolling it gives you a
reaction force or gives you a helps put
you back a tumble home is shaped you
know the opposite direction and if you
have a ship shaped in that direction it
doesn't have as much of a restoring
Force when you roll but what is the idea
with making a ship like that there's a
lot of different reasons why you want to
change a whole design some of you is the
above water signatures it's all about
the shape and radar sections and you
know that there's a lot that goes into
that we always want to be stealthier you
always want to be faster you always want
to have more power and that's always
what you know the Innovations come
so most of the sailors aren't aware of
the work that's going on in the
background to support
what they do when I was in The Fleets
and I've been in the Navy 27 years I
never had any idea certainly not the
magnitude of what they do
I'm not exaggerating when I say it's
impacted every ship and submarine in the
fleet
Warriors
hey if you don't have a huge wave pool
in your house to test out wave physics I
suggest you check out brilliant the
sponsor of this video brilliant is the
best learning tool I know for mastering
Concepts in math science and computer
science all their lessons are built
around interactivity just check out this
one on buoyancy you can adjust the size
of a void in this block and see whether
it sinks or floats and then you proceed
through a series of increasingly
challenging questions and simulations
you know what I love about brilliant is
that it really gets me thinking so when
I complete a lesson I feel a sense of
accomplishment because I figured it out
myself and this applies to their
fundamentals courses as well as to their
more advanced topics for example the
wave principles of superposition and
interference also apply to their course
on quantum mechanics which I found to be
both engaging and really comprehensive
this is a great interactive which forces
you to deeply engage with the conditions
that lead to interference a concept I
know a lot of students struggle with
brilliant keeps supporting veritasium I
think for two reasons first they know
that viewers of this channel are smart
and they want to understand things
deeply so a lot of you have already
signed up and second I know that some of
you haven't given it a try yet so I
guess my question is what are you
waiting for you can try it out for free
right now by going to brilliant.org
veritasium and finally I want to remind
you that with the holiday season coming
up you can give the gift of brilliant to
a friend or family member that clever
person in your life who is really into
stem there are courses tailored for
anyone whether beginner intermediate or
Advanced and if you sign up right now
brilliant are offering 20 off an annual
premium subscription to the first 200
people to sign up just use my link
brilliant.org veritasium so I want to
thank brilliant for supporting
veritasium and I want to thank you for
watching